as our anime heroes go through their
everyday lives
they're often pulled along by various
emotions more often than not they
encounter numerous obstacles or
circumstances that they fall prey to
circumstances where regardless of their
good intentions things just don't seem
to be going their way and finally we see
them snap this is one of the most primal
emotions we see anime characters
encounter during their journey well more
often than not this isn't really the
solution but once in a while this rage
and fury can indeed help them out of the
predicament their rim so on that note
today we'll be discussing the top 10
anime main characters rage moments
without further ado let's get on with
the list
[Music]
we start off with now Foom ease rate
moment from the ongoing anime of rising
of the shield hero after witnessing
fellow being swallowed by the zombie
dragon we see our hero become consumed
by the hatred and rage boiling within
him come out in a really terrifying and
amazing display no fool meas realistic
and unfortunate character in how the
people of the world he has to save
misjudged him so badly his anger and
hatred is quite understandable and even
relatable in the despair of losing all
he gained he completely gives in to the
anger and hatred within him this was
quite an emotional rollercoaster of an
episode that released a lot of the rage
and hatred generated by the storyline so
far
[Music]
Oh Maya dorita moving on our next moment
comes from bleach it's the fight between
ulquiorra and ichigo this was when
ichigo transforms into a vast Oh Lord it
was an epic moment where Ichigo could be
said to turn into rage incarnate after
the transformation he immediately rushes
head-on into ulquiorra trying to kill
him he's not even conscious and just
trying to destroy his enemy the actions
really intense here with the situation
quickly being turned leaving you at the
edge of your seats
it was also touching how all key aura
ends up and it was a really good job on
the part of the creator to make us
actually feel somewhat sorry for the
seemingly heartless villain who punched
a hole through ichigo's chest
[Music]
the next moment on our list is from mob
psycho the epic rage moment when mob
faces off against cuellar mah kwahm is a
member of the group known as scar that
collects espers around the globe in an
attempt at world domination he's
assigned to capture mob but mistakes
mobs brother Ritsu as his intended
target however the way kramer treats
Ritsu and the gang of delinquents in
rages mob to the point where he goes to
100% power fueled by that rage what
follows is a one-sided beat down with
Kwai Armour sustaining severe damage
he's completely overwhelmed
my tsunami won on day number seven on a
list is a really popular and a fan
favorite scene from one piece this
specific moment is when luffy punches
the celestial dragon not exactly from a
fight or battle scene but nonetheless
it's one of the most powerful rage
moments ever the scene setup was done
really well
the celestial dragons are considered the
most important people in the world in
terms of authority and the power they
control in the form of the world
government the moment when hot shine
gets shot was frustrating but the payoff
we got when luffy gets pissed off is
simply amazing if anything this felt
like righteous rage and was so
satisfying to watch even the way the
animation changes to black and white in
the style of the manga really added a
lot of drama to the moment
[Music]
[Music]
waring on Eureka
[Music]
number six on our list is Naruto's rage
moment against pain pain was a really
good antagonist with his backstory and
beliefs it really brought the contrast
of the hope that Naruto represents
bringing an epic clash of inevitability
versus perseverance the specific moment
we'd like to discuss is when pain
stamped Hinata as she intervenes in the
fight and is seemingly killed this is
where Naruto snaps and willingly
releases the nine tails what followed
was some of the best fight sequences
that the show's produced watching this
moment was quite intense and how the
emotions were handled was simply amazing
enough to give you goosebumps
[Music]
our next moment comes from attack on
Titan specifically the moment in the
fight against Annie this moment comes
when Aaron's somewhat defeated by Annie
after he'd initially charged her and
fought her he finally loses it and goes
berserk in an epic and terrifying
fashion he launches on to Annie
senselessly beating her down this form
has been coined as berserk mode by some
fans that was frightening to watch Aaron
can be defined by his anger and this
scene captures the pure unbridled rage
within him he loses track of everything
even the fact that they're fighting
inside the walls he lets go and throws
everything at Annie losing his underarm
in the process without care and
proceeding to use his mouth to inflict
harm quite an intense moment now
wouldn't you agree to join us
come on up the hill
number four on our list comes from Dora
it's the scene where he akamaru goes on
a rampage after me oh and the children
are killed the world of Dora is a tragic
place the circumstances of our hero are
also one of highly unfortunate origins
after mios duties and both the enemy
camps she was marked as a spy and
samurai are sent to kill her and
everyone living with her when he akamaru
comes back after defeating the demon he
completely loses it and kills everyone
blinded by sadness and rage it's a very
emotional episode showing that the
journey ahead is not a hopeful one it
was heartbreaking to see the first word
he ever speaks is Neos name number two
on the list is guts rage moment from
berserk no list on rage moments can
ignore this moment this is easily the
most glorious and brutal visual
representation of rage on this list well
who wouldn't go mad when the family you
know and the woman you love are being
tortured and destroyed right in front of
your own eyes that too by a man who you
considered to be a dear friend this was
a hard scene to swallow with its bare
despair and terror imposed on us and the
people we've come to know so much about
he did anything he could to kill and was
truly berserk in every sense of the word
it's not just an epic rage moment but
also one of the most iconic and shocking
moments we got to witness in both manga
and
what Emily
and finally at number one we have gone
rage moment from Hunter hunter this was
one of the biggest moments in the series
for fans of the show
the conflict between gone and be thaw is
completely and very emotionally charged
until now gone shown as the positive
friendly protagonist we've all come to
love that positivity is sorely crushed
as his hopes of being able to save kite
are dashed causing him to finally give
everything in killing booth of the
animation and the background music that
illustrate the range of emotions these
characters are experiencing is simply
hair-raising
chorus
[Music]
and so with this we conclude today's
video did you enjoy our list which is
your favorite moment make sure you
comment below and let me know thank you
for giving us a watch and do subscribe
to stay tuned for new videos I'll see
you next time on mini tube
[Music]
[Music]